jan ist ein ziemlich kurzes und viel zu
heftiges vergnügen dass auf mallorca
stattgefunden hat aufgrund von illegalen
partys werden nun die lokale auf der
beliebten bier und schinkenstraße am
ballermann zwangs geschlossen
das geht ab sofort um zunächst für die
kommenden zwei monate
schuld daran sind auch diese bilder die
uns am wochenende erreicht hatten wir
sehen viele viele touristen am
ballermann dicht gedrängt ohne masken
von corona maßnahmen hat hier wohl noch
niemand gehört oder besser gesagt es
interessiert die partywütigen einfach
nicht das könnt ihr jetzt das aus für
den ballermann für dieses jahr sein und
genau darüber möchte ich jetzt sprechen
mit unseren sparfuchs frank ochse ist
beim jahren hülle frank derzeit der
ballermann und sowieso mallorca gerade
erst aufgemacht für die touristen wieder
wie bitter ist das jetzt also für die
insel
auf jeden fall sehr bitter für die
gastronomen tatsächlich ist es nach
corinna die zweite große katastrophe
die haben jetzt offen neuanfang gehofft
und müssen jetzt wirklich zwang
schließen muss man sich mal vorstellen
dass gab es wirklich noch nie also das
ist die stehen quasi vor dem nichts weil
so langsam ging es los so langsam ging
es wieder bergauf und natürlich sind das
auch sehen die wollte da niemand sehen
auch sicherlich nicht die gastronomen
aber wirklich ganz bitter für die jetzt
ist aber auch die frage wie sieht sonst
auf mallorca aus mussten touristen jetzt
generell mit strengeren regeln auf der
insel wieder rechnen wenn sie dort in
urlaub fahren die spanier sind wirklich
sehr nervös haben angst natürlich für
steigenden infektionszahlen insofern ist
es schon auch brisant also auch normale
menschen die vielleicht in anderen
landesteilen dort urlaub machen wollen
müssen tatsächlich jetzt dann bedrängnis
da auch strengere maßnahmen gibt das
heißt also dieser fall spricht
eigentlich für die nervosität der
spanier und auch für das knallharte
durchgreifen
das heißt also es ist da vielleicht auch
noch andere mit anderen verschärfung zu
rechnen
was müssen oder worauf müssen
sommerurlaub jetzt generell besonders
achten
ja wir haben jetzt gerade am auch wieder
der band gibt es jetzt eine sehr strenge
masken pflicht also tatsächlich auch
wenn ich auf der straße nur gehe an das
jetzt als hier muss sich eine maske
tragen auf der strandpromenade nicht ich
finde das sind schon ganz schön eine
einschränkung für den urlaub und mit
sowas ist halt auch in zukunft wirklich
zu rechnen das geht aber nicht nur am
ballermann sondern für die gesamte in
ja ja